في وقت تصاعدت فيه التوترات منذ شهور بين
الجارتين اذربيجان وايران تعرضت سفاره
اذربيجان الواقعه وجمال العاصمه طهران
لهجوم المسلح اسفر عن مقتل رئيس امنها
ويدعى اورخان رضوان اوغلو عسكروف وجرح
حارسين
اظهر مقطع فيديو للمراقبه من خارج السفاره
ان المسرح الذي تم توقيفه صدم سيارته
باخرى امام السفاره ثم نزل امام الحارس
الموجود داخل جناح شرطه الايرانيه الذي لم
يقاوم واعطاه المسلح وعلامه تحيه بيده
ووقف ساكنا ولم يفعل شيئا
بحسب موقع قناه الايرانيه المعارضه فان
الهجوم على السفاره هو سيناريو مخططا له
مسبقا من قبل الحرس الثوري الايراني وفي
فيديو اخر من داخل السفاره اخترق المهاجم
ونقطه الحراسه وقتل مسؤول الامن ببندقيه
كلاشنكوف بينما كان يطارد الرجال الى مكتب
جانبيا صغير ومن ثم ظهر احد الرجال من باب
الجانبيه وقاتل المسلحه للامساك بالبندقيه
رئيس اذربيجان وصف الهجوم على سفاره بلاد
في طهران بالعمل الارهابي مطالبا بالتحقيق
ومحاسبه المسؤولين الخارجيه الاذربيجانيه
وجهت اصابع الاتهام الى ايران
بتجاهلي دعوتها لتعزيز الامن في سفاراتها
بظهران مشيره الى ان الحمله المناهضه لباك
في ايران ساهمت في الهجوم رشا خياط
العربيه